this is of an historical unprecedented
nature if you've got 250 to 300 000
people
net
coming into a country
[Music]
every year that is extraordinary
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
host of the new culture forum right here
on youtube peter whittle welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much concert
tim francis it's great to be here it's
fantastic to have you slightly novel
experience
but you know great all the better you're
in the other chair now the interrogation
will begin shortly uh but no look it's
great to have you on you have a great
program uh here on youtube not only
interviews in a similar vein to what we
do but also you make documentaries and
all sorts of other stuff uh before we
get into all of that tell us a little
bit about who are you who am i how are
you where you are what has been your
journey through life because it has been
an interesting one i think you're going
to say it has been a long one yeah
it has been a longer the longer it is
the more interesting it usually is as
well
no um yeah i mean basically uh first of
all i've always been interested in
politics i mean i think for about 12 or
13
and we had to kind of found my family
with some family used to talk about
politics
a lot not in a kind of terribly informed
way but they used about current events
um and
i grew up in in london i a born and bred
londoner
and my parents are from peckham
and uh they moved out when i was just a
baby to a place called shooters hill
south london yeah i know you know it
right a lot of people don't know it
actually but it's one of the highest
points in london
and um you know so and then i've lived
and worked in london almost my entire
life apart from five years when i spent
in um in los angeles but
but uh essentially uh yeah college all
of that um
but
i suppose
my life in terms of work right alone has
been essentially
in a kind of creative media field i
think i got the tail end
of when the media was sort of good when
tv was still good
uh certainly for making documentaries
and i used to work for something called
the south bank show which is a older
viewers will absolutely know it was like
a an iconic program and then after that
covered the new uh arts culture film
theater all of that
for um
the sunday times and people like this
and
and then i suppose what brought me to a
point with starting the new culture
forum which we did in 2006
was that
it just
i did not like the way things were going
i mean we didn't know then what would be
coming down the pipeline you know but
this at the time i was
i had this kind of
i cam came back from america
and i thought
i don't like how this country is is
going um what does that mean peter uh
because 2006 it's way before what we now
call woke culture or this sort of or not
well no not really i mean there was
already a kind of thing in the air you
know that there was a there was there
was a set of orthodox views
and it went through the cultural section
of our society went through all the
institutions really
um and one was thinking well
actually we've got to sort of challenge
this in some way we've got to challenge
these orthodoxies what were they so that
it was multiculturalism was great
uh
climate change
um all the things that's still the case
now
um immigration was an unalloyed good
um also that basically we should
not britain was bad but that somehow our
other patriotism was bad
all of those things which in fact
pretty much are in place now with knobs
on
um
before that well i was still in america
uh when 9 11 happened when i was living
on the west coast
it was like a kind of epiphany because
i'd kind of dropped out of being
interested in politics i used to be
active in the tory party and everything
and i i dropped dropped out of it
because i i was far more interested in
my media career and doing all that stuff
and uh
9 11 suddenly it was like this i think
christopher hitchens said the same thing
that it was like this epiphany the times
come to get serious actually this was
serious
and it was from that moment on actually
that i really started to
become much more uh involved again
started the ntf for a few years after
after that that's a bit of a whirlwind
to a hell of a lot else has gone on but
i mean you know i hope you know it gives
you an idea for our form and you were
involved in politics directly as well
yeah i was yeah ukip for six years
um
six years about 2013 i think
and uh i became their culture spokesman
people used to find that hilarious you
know
culture what does that mean
you know basically they thought we would
all have union jet waistcoats
and you know and and all of that
bulldogs and all of that but i was asked
by them you know because of the ncf new
culture form would you would you uh be
our culture spokesman it was very wide
it wasn't just like the arts and
everything it was all these cultural
issues which you guys talk about on your
program we do all the time
um because they are the big issues of of
our time
and um so i did that and then um i
became deputy leader of ukip
and then basically stood for the emery
in london 2016
got onto the london assembly that body
that nobody's ever heard of even in
london
you know so i was up against the car all
the time you know and all of that um but
i would say with ukip um
for about two years in the middle of
that it was
absolutely fantastic it really was
you know it was
we were right in the middle
of and had indeed i would say caused
some of the main events of the time the
referendum
and um i think that there were very good
people involved and you really felt that
this was something that was making a
difference in fact of course it did make
a difference
so i think
particularly i think
2015-16
was a fantastic time in uk peter can i
challenge you a little bit on this idea
that it made a difference because
there's no question that the referendum
was a huge event in in human history i
would argue in terms of the cascading
consequences around the world
potentially but one of the issues we're
seeing now is one of the the principal
arguments in favor of brexit was the
ability to control immigration something
that i personally i voted romaine but
the idea that a country should control
its borders doesn't seem particularly
controversial to me i'm racist
it started with me to go over yeah
exactly
but here we are now it's 2021 almost
2022 brexit
was delivered boris johnson is in power
on the basis that he would deliver
brexit are we controlling our borders of
course not i mean
uh and i don't disagree with you at all
i think
that that is about
something else um
we should be able to
uh
with brexit definitely or indeed you
know actually even before brexit we
could have controlled them more
but i would say that there isn't the
will to do it
and that goes across the whole
establishment really
and
i don't know whether you remember but
just i think a week ago
before filming this
uh it emerged that the head of the
border force
was pretty anti-borders
now
even for someone like me who thinks that
the establishment's riddled with left
liberal people even though you sort of
think surely not i mean
surely not there was this guy the quote
was the borders are a pain in the ass i
think his voice
but then i think he started going on us
we're all
mammals or something we're all species
or something like you know but
what it didn't do is instill any
confidence that this person actually
really believed in his job and you sort
of think well actually you're not about
to take people on who are very very
uh
rigorous about immigration are you
you're not you know you're not gonna and
that i thought was very very
telling i i think
that immigration is probably
the most important issue actually uh
that we face historically
um so it's not
that
brexit
was never going to control immigration
well you've got to have the will to do
it
you know i mean to his uh credit nigel
has been going down to the south coast
and filming all of that
um
but um i wouldn't say that's a failure
of brexit it's a failure of our entire
political class
peter why do you think it's one of the
most important if i think you said the
most important issue of our time i think
it is and i think it is actually for
most people
um
it's of historic proportions i mean
i'm not
uh anti-immigration at all i don't think
i know anyone who is actually in
principle
um and it would be hypocritical because
i went and i went to another country you
know be utterly uh
hypocritical
i think that what we're seeing is
on you know this is of an historical
unprecedented nature if you've got 250
to 300 000 people
net
coming into a country
every year that is extraordinary we now
that is normal
now no one really even reports it very
much
and
so many of the issues that we
talk about whether it's housing whatever
it is cultural change whatever it is
um all of these things uh
are absolutely
um
there's no point in even discussing them
if you're not going to at least look at
immigration too
and when i was on the london assembly
for example
five years
i was on it
not once did immigration get discussed
and london
basically has been transformed by
immigration
within a generation
and um i think you know that
economically it's incredibly important
but also culturally it's important i
don't see why people should be
sort of feel inhibited or rather should
i i say i do know why they should be
inhibited because they're frightened of
talking about it i think it's the same
old thing they're going to be called
this and the other thing
so in fact i'd say that there's less
talk about immigration now than even
10 years ago actually i don't know if
you feel i agree
less talk it's a sex oh well that's just
the way it is
what it seems to me is this we had the
referendum which was ostensibly about
immigration it was about controlling our
borders it was about people saying that
actually we as an island and as a nation
we should be able to decide who enters
the country and who doesn't freedom of
movement doesn't work and that's
something i believe in and actually my
mother is an immigrant right and i do
not believe it's racist in any shape or
form to say that but it seems to me what
we have
is we have the vast majority of the
population who believe that
and then we have the government
and the political class who are not
wishing to enact what the public want
and that seems to me a very major
problem in our society well is as i said
is one of the main ones
but in fact you could go through a whole
raft of issues
where that is the case uh where the
majority of people feel one thing
they watch these illegal
you know landings coming in saying
what is going on
why why is it so difficult to stop this
if you look back over the past year what
a government can really do when it wants
to
you know
so you don't you could go back and say
well what about the iraq war same thing
a government can do something who wants
to
and
extraordinary levels of regulation have
been put in and
with covet and all of that and whatever
you think about that the fact is is that
it can be done and yet we can't do this
simple thing
we can't do this simple thing like
control our borders but what we have now
is even more interesting in that we have
a home secretary who talks tough but
actually doesn't seem to be controlling
or isn't controlling the borders at all
whereas before we had people fudging the
issue and being merely mouthed now we
have someone who talks tough but
doesn't deliver
no it's uh all window addressing i'm
afraid it was it's the same generally
with the this government for me
uh you know when we had the
cultural attacks of last year and the
statues and all of that being attacked
um
what did they really say i mean they you
know they said say if you know this is
bad and no we can't
but there's no sense really in which
they're taking this very seriously not
really i don't even think they
understand it
this is the amazing thing to me peter
and you know from neither francis or i a
conservative uh in in certainly in the
party sense we both have conservative
values on certain things but
i i thought that the the political
situation in 2019 when the red wall
collapsed and working-class people came
over to the tory party
on a number of issues obviously brexit
was one of them but also i think it was
a pushback against what people now call
the woke agenda the work culture
whatever people felt very strongly that
they were going to vote for a party that
doesn't buy into this stuff
and yet here we are two years later
people voted for that i i mean if i was
a red
wall voter i don't imagine i'd be
feeling that this government is
delivering and they'd be right to feel
that
yeah so so the problem for me there is
there is no democratic way out at the
moment for people who who have these
concerns as you do no and you know
there's a lot of talk you'll be aware
you know if you swim in these
political
ponds that we're in uh there's a lot of
talk why can't all the small parties get
together
the fact is is that look um with ukip
and then with the brexit party i suppose
um they did what they were meant to do
they were extremely effective pressure
groups that became elected or at least
in the case if you get became elected
what they did they frightened the tories
simple as that frightened cameron
because the one thing that moves these
people
is when they fear for their seats for
their electoral states and if they
really and they saw you keep going up
not like that
so what i've been saying over the past
you know a year to anyone or listen is
basically we need somebody to do this
but for these issues we're talking about
now
um when it comes to the tories um i
genuinely think many of them don't quite
get it i mean you know they when you
talk to them bless them um they sort of
say i think yes oh it's all a load of
nonsense um you know political
correctness gone mad you know you sort
of think you don't quite get what this
is i mean for me
what we're living with at the moment is
an outright attack
on our civilization actually
and uh i think that they don't grasp
that
when you go further up people like boris
and people like that obviously these are
intelligent people for goodness sake um
it's just a matter of expediency this
requires
real courage to actually face these sort
of things what are you gonna do you know
if you've got
universities that don't
uh believe particularly in free speech
and actually impose the opposite you've
got a border controlled chief who
doesn't believe in borders you've got a
police
force which appears to have been
entirely captured
um by this kind of woke mentality
no wonder people feel
not just frustrated but actually sort of
they feel
unhelped and powerless
and uh there's no one actually really uh
basically answering their fears and
their worries
but i think it's i'm afraid it's down to
the government in that way you know that
they just simply haven't got
uh the guts or the knowledge really to
do
what needs to
be done and then that is a whole
different argument about what you should
do should you start new institutions
should you start new universities i i
noticed you've had um kathleen stockholm
recently she's gone to austin isn't it
universal it's not quite started yet but
this is what we've got to do
you believe that new institutions oh yes
you're never going to reform these
things why not
because um
it's too ingrained now you know it's
it's all of it's too ingrained uh
you are just going to have to offer
alternatives well look we're sitting in
one aren't we
you know when it comes to uh
uh media we're you know trying to you
fellas
we're trying to offer
something else
i would say in fact this is the new form
of
public broadcasting actually stuff you
would never see anymore so there's that
but i think when it comes to
universities or you know other
institutions
uh we have got to start really seriously
thinking right we've got to start
creating our own
things you know
very very difficult to do america tends
to be much better at that kind of thing
they've got more money
they've got more people willing to put
their money where their mouth is than we
have
but um to go back to my original point
yes um
i think
you know people often
tend to focus on boris and say well he's
always been a metropolitan liberal and
all that that might be true but i think
a lot of it there is just simply
not really the will
you know
um
you know whatever you think of macron
uh
he came out during the
cultural kerfuffle last year and said
you know this does not happen in france
we do not take statues down we do not do
this that the other front bubble and you
saw that why god are
senior politicians
just simply give people reassurance in
that way and they just can't
and why why is that peter who who are
they afraid of i think that they are
basically afraid of the people that they
mix with
seriously i mean it just comes down to
that
um i think also as i said there's a
great
inability to understand
if you were to say like i've just said
about the attack on
western civilization which i think is is
happening
uh if you would say that to
many senior toys they would say yes okay
you know yeah all when it's terrible
itself they don't really i don't think
they really take it on board
on the issue of immigration i think it's
a our good old-fashioned friend fear of
being called
racist or xenophobic plus the civil
service which is absolutely solidly
not on board with it
hey constantine do you like christmas no
in ussr we canceled christmas and we had
lenion fest instead hosa we celebrated
glorious leader and rewrote story of
jesus to make it better really yes in
our story three wise men were killed and
gifts meant for jesus redistributed to
glorious workers of the soviet union
jesus was put in gulag for having wrong
opinion as we call it in russia happy
ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes is discussion with
one of our favorite guests aisha akanbi
she is almost as good philosopher as
vladimir lenin
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are excellent
you say it's an attack on our on on our
civilization those are very bold words
peter i mean you've given a couple of
examples you've given the universities
with the problems with freedom of speech
which i completely agree with
you you gave the example of the head of
the borders
statute statues please police
what else is there well i would say like
this is not some conspiracy theory i'm
talking about uh at all it's not a
conspiracy theory it doesn't have to be
um
i think that when you look at the way in
which for example
creativity in the arts
literature
film uh paintings all of these things
music
um one by one they've sort of been
picked off so in america at the moment
classical music is very much under the
hammer
as being an expression of white
supremacy right um now if you say that
even though in your mind you're thinking
what a crock of crap that is to say that
at the same time you'll be thinking well
if i maybe go against saying that i will
get it in the neck you know from the
usual people particularly i'm on twitter
and all of that so fear plays a part
but
the problem is with these things is is
increasingly
uh when it comes to any uh creative
endeavor
of the sort that underpins our
civilization
um
it's increasingly about
you can't write about that
uh
you can only write or paint or whatever
it is
your lived experience right that kills
creativity
and even though people might say oh it
it doesn't really because um you know
you can always say yep no it does
because also people who might want to
say something else for example are just
simply not going to bother they're not
going to go go there also it leads to
enormous self-censorship too i mean i
think that the arts for example could
really be
you know killing themselves at the
moment you know
so and i think that you might say well
people say well i don't really care
about the arts you know why should we
pay for them anyway well
you know i mean the fact is that they're
a huge part of our civilization and our
achievements
and we're seeing them basically being
chipped chipped away out and the thing
that i find really frustrating with the
arts and particularly with comedy but it
goes right the way through i'm i'm a
huge theater lover i love going to the
theater one of the i used to but i don't
anymore yeah and i think part of the
reason is is because i sit down and i
and i watch something i just want to be
told a story i want emotions i want
characters i want
i want to live in a different world for
two and a half three hours what i don't
want is a tedious lecture and it
sometimes feels like you go you go to
watch these things and i'm being told
how to live and that to me is not art i
don't want perfect people no i mean it's
not yeah but they're not all so perfect
are they that's the same i think it's i
mean when it comes to i was a film
critic for what 20 years for all sorts
of different people
um and uh i've always loved them i've
lost interest
a bit lately i have to say because i'm
not interested in marvel comics and
that's the mainstream output now isn't
it yes it is and i just can't get
interested but you sort of know when
you're being lectured
and it's sort of got this rather
wearing type of predictability about it
here we go
i think that that
with the theater you mentioned for
example
when did you last see a political drama
at the theater francis
that sort of
i don't know even sort of
gave a kind of balanced view of i mean
could you imagine
a play which i would have thought would
be quite good dramatically actually
about sort of
working class people in the red wall uh
who voted for brexit um
it wouldn't have to be
just about it could be the background to
the play like you know and you've got to
have a drama and everything
it doesn't have to be crude but
the idea that that would happen is sort
of unthinkable yeah
yeah well you see this that's wrong
isn't it
it's completely wrong you know i mean
what i remember when we first started
the new culture form one of the reasons
i did was i went to interview nicholas
heitner who at the time was director of
the national theatre and uh he'd come up
this thing he said what we need and what
we need in british theater
is we need
good naughty you know right wing plays
you know
uh to mix it up a bit and i sort of
thought that tells you everything that
phrase you know
naughty you know it's sort of basically
just let's let's let a few in
and that was back then
but i think the chances now of having
real variety of thought
you know in something like the theater
is just gone
it's gone i mean it's interesting you
say that peter because a good friend of
ours jeff norcot the comedian yes uh he
made a career he was a great comic
before but he made a tv career you might
say by focusing on on the fact that he
voted brexit and he was the sort of
human humanized face of brexit in the
comedy world where he's a lovely guy
jeff and so he's a lot easier to hear
than maybe but then but then everyone
just went oh okay so we've got that
covered now
and and that's it and it seems like
culture has been holed in in this very
narrow way and it's interesting what you
say about cinema as well because i used
to go to cinema all the time i used to
watch the bbc all the time i used to do
all that stuff and now i really don't we
see what i don't know whether people i
read an article i think it was i can't
remember celia warden i think it was but
she wrote she she she wrote an article
quite recently i thought you know that's
really you put your finger on it um
you wake up in the morning what is going
to be wrong with something i liked
yesterday
what what should i feel guilty about
um but you know i feel that
you know it's like once hinterland is
being scraped away so you can actually
list what don't you do anymore
what don't you i mean i mean interviewed
on the channel where victor um
davis hansen you know
you've had him yeah and uh he was saying
i don't yeah i don't i don't watch the
super bowl anymore i don't uh certainly
don't watch the uh news network news
i don't watch the oscars um that's
same for me i don't know about you i
don't watch tv mainstream tv anymore um
it's not good for your mental health
mm-hmm um and but also just
you know i used to like have i got news
for you yeah it was usually quite like
it yeah and you think no i why should i
watch and laugh along when you
so disapprove of the likes of me
why should i and and it's the same when
you get uh people in in
film and showbiz in america who come out
with this deplorables line
and make such a fuss about it and you
sort of think people will stop buying
tickets
you know eventually if you do this if
you carry on because they're going to
sort of people have hardened their
attitudes hard and saying why why should
i why should i indirectly give you money
you think i'm cheers
it's it's you know uh it was a couple of
months ago uh i got the guys we we have
we had a big screen at our last studio
and i got the big screen up and i put on
i mean it's gonna sound very nerdy but i
put on
prime minister's questions
between william hague and john prescott
deputy prime minister
and this won't say much to our american
audience but it's fascinating to watch
because it's this very posh
extremely articulate william hague
debating with a working class in
articular
well you could argue in articular john
prescott and they're both playing their
character and john prescott doesn't go
oh you're oppressing me the
working-class man because you're making
fun of my grandma he goes well you're
making fun of my grandma but my judgment
is and there was a a kind of mutual
appreciation
that would have been what 20 years ago
yeah it was
1998 maybe well people are still adults
you see well i was going to ask you i
mean
it's that's a a funny quip but do you
think maybe
is it social media that's done this to
us not not entirely i think it certainly
hasn't helped
you mean the general deterioration in
public uh
discourse yeah like everything is
everything is fight now and
and it's fight to the death yes yeah um
yes i think uh
that's true social media is is part of
it although there's been a slight change
in the sense that
as well is that people
uh because of the kind of cult of
narcissism and
they sort of feel you know um they're
not used to being criticized anymore
uh not just on social media but
the way that many kids are brought up
now
um and so
you know there's this whole thing of you
know
being kept safe from things that you
don't like or disagree with
it makes people therefore very angry
when they disagree with very very angry
so i think that might be one of the
reasons i think as well that when it
comes to parliament
um i would say there has been a kind of
deterioration and kind of
people you know even i think very
visibly
you know um
over the past sort of ten years
i completely agree with you that there
is why would you go into it
i mean why would you go into it if you
are going to have
everything you said
you know what just brought up from like
10 years ago what kind of a person is
still going to go yeah i want some of
that yeah and you're going to be badly
paid and you're going to be criticized
for every single thing you say or do
you're going to become a hate figure
particularly if you're on the right i
would say or if you're on the far left
you're going to become a hate figure
you're going to get people sending you
death threats and rape threats every day
on twitter you're not being remunerated
for it particularly well
what's the appeal yes what's the appeal
i i think it has
you know it it has deteriorated
definitely i don't know what i mean just
just uh proper this is what we've been
discussing i don't know whether you guys
get this i'm sure you do
on this point of the political class
not absolutely not really responding to
people
you get emails don't you and letters i
certainly do
all the time yeah and
people are genuinely bewildered
and
genuinely
just so upset during the whole stuff
with the start we started his campaign
save our statute
uh when we were
did that
the level the visceral
a hurt people felt
the kind of
landscape heritage being attacked uh
was huge you know but see the thing is
peter and i'm sorry to interrupt but the
reason is is the far left
yeah but i know but i like
listening to people talking hearing
their points of view it's why we do this
is but
i think what the far left don't get for
instance when the chur when the statue
of churchill was attacked
my grandfather volunteered
to go and fight he could he could have
he was building mosquito planes during
the war he was a master carpenter he
didn't have to go and fight but he
volunteered to go and fight the nazis
and fought right the way from italy
right the way down to north africa and
in fort in the battle of el alamein yeah
to basically save the west
and then when i saw that statue being
attacked and defaced of churchill to me
it was not only were they disrespecting
my country not only were they
disrespecting a political symbol they
were disrespecting my grandfather and
his memory and they don't understand
that they don't get that because
to them i think they have their utopians
they want to live in this world without
borders they want us to live in this
place where you know we overcome racism
and all these different things
but the reality is it's not the real
world they've been indoctrinated in
utopianism do you not think that is i i
i i totally get the point by your gram
yeah
and i feel that when you look at the the
white poppy thing yeah you know i sort
of think that's a kind of implied insult
actually because it's implying that
people who wear red poppy somehow love
war
you know no i think the thing is really
on that point
francis is it's i don't think to say
that they are utopian
is sort of
it gives them a kind of it's it's too
nice
i mean in the sense that you can say oh
it's great to be idealistic
and
okay they might get it wrong but they're
idealistic i don't think that you see i
think that it's it's it's a lot of it is
hate
uh i think that
you know one of the things that we've
talked about a lot at the ncfs or over
the years is the
kind of culture of self-hatred um
it attack anything which is to do with
the nation
uh anything which is to do with the
traditional family anything which is to
do with basically the way we might do
things
so in other words i don't think they're
motive to say that i'm you know it's
utopian we want to live in a world
i'm not so sure i think a lot of it is
based purely on resentment
and anger
and and dislike dislike of what they are
dislike of
you know uh do you not think country do
not think so for instance when it comes
to the blm thing for example now the
people at the top may be like that but
there's a vast wave of people i think
blm was is deeply sinister as an
organization because what i think they
did is they exploited black people's
pain of the fact that they've had racism
and you know it's particularly when you
look at the first generation of
immigrants who came to this country in
the 50s or 60s or 70s they faced awful
awful racism and prejudice and what they
did i think was
essentially weaponize that pain in order
to try and fulfill their political ends
yeah i think i think that i'd agree with
that but i i think also it's interesting
because obviously i you know growing up
yes britain was far more casually racist
then there's no getting away from it you
know but
it certainly isn't now and it seems that
what's happening it's the same with the
the gay uh with stonewall and the gay
thing is essentially when things have
actually improved a huge amount of
course then people start to lose their
point
so suddenly
it's even worse i mean if if an alien
came
down now and look to britain they would
sort of think god what is this racist
cesspit you know because everywhere in
in every newspaper you know every news
bullet it's racism racism racism whereas
we all i think would believe and concede
that actually this is remarkably
tolerant country and in fact certainly
isn't maybe what it was like
when uh immigrants first arrived um you
know certainly
i would say therefore that the people
who uh protest
not just blm but just generally uh what
we're
dealing with at the moment are people
who on the whole
just do not like
uh
their culture they don't they do not
like their country they do not like the
society
i think people who really have a strong
sense of you know injustice and you know
wanting to make things better for
ordinary people
um i think uh you you can tell those
people those sincere people you can and
that used to be labor
actually my parents were uh patriotic
uh they uh they liked the queen um and
they uh we were just you know
they felt part of something
we they use we all the time well we
don't usually we don't
we we tend not to be like that you know
what they meant was the
country you know the british
um but they were labor they voted labor
and they weren't sort of like
absolute believers in the kind of uh
free market uh evangelical
sort of evangelical uh oh the market
will solve everything and all of that
they certainly weren't they had a very
strong sense actually of justice in that
way
um which i think was very strong in the
labour party i'd say up to about 60s
but you know and then basically you know
like so many people they went over they
went over to to thatcher
because
labour was becoming
already then in
hawk to these sort of smaller
influential groups and you know just
becoming unrecognizable so it used to be
low i think there was a genuine i think
in fact i find it very very moving if
you go back to the beginning
before you know the very beginnings of
trade unions movement and also the way
in which
working people
uh used to have
classes in literature
and and in mining communities and things
like that all of these things was just
wonderful aspirational it's good to know
this stuff
good to know this
that's entirely gone i think to the
point where i think
actually people
probably don't even know existed really
peter let me ask you something because i
agree with you on the resentment point
actually i do think this is what drives
a chunk of that uh stephen hicks i don't
know if you've had him on your show he's
a canadian philosopher i really i should
introduce you he's very good we're going
to have him on the show very soon again
he talks about the fact that there are
different traditions on the left and one
of them is solidarity based what you're
talking about with your parents and the
other one is the resentment left
and they've come in
undoubtedly and they've made their
impact on the world which is fine people
are allowed to have whatever in my
opinion their political views that's
absolutely fine the question for me
is
why are these people being
indulged
why are these people being given the
opportunity we had as you sit here now
this morning there's a story that the
imperial war museum
had uh an anti-churchill
woke wrap
performed on remembrance sunday
right now people are allowed to perform
anti-churchill woke wraps that is the
country we live in you would defend free
speech i'm sure as much as i would
absolutely
but why is that happening at the
imperial war museum
like that's what i don't understand is i
understand people having a resentful
view of society and we've covered it on
the show a lot the breakdown of the
family all sorts of other factors cause
people to not like their circumstances
to be upset to be traumatized from
childhood that's fine they're allowed to
feel that
why are the adults in the room
pandering to that
well i would say uh the you know in the
case of the imperial war museum or
almost any museum you want to mention
um
i think that there has been uh all of
our
main institutions have sort of been
captured
um what i think was
very telling is that during the blm
thing you know last year
um
it was the speed with which all of these
institutions suddenly started saying
we're decolonizing we're decolonized you
had the uh death of
george floyd then you had you know these
statues and the blm and everything and
then this started to happen very very
quickly
in almost identical so they had the
british
library decolonizing its uh collection
this is like the spine of the culture
the british library
they're going through the spine and
essentially we're going to sort of start
you know tinkering with that
and then you had it the same with the
national gallery we're looking at all of
our slavery routes
you had national maritime yeah all of
them
and uh you know you almost you can
there's one a week
um i would say that the same sort of
people
uh run them
um they have
broadly they dislike i think
our heritage the national trust of
course being another brilliant one um
they are full of guilt
um
and also they tend to be quite ignorant
actually
of the very thing they're meant to be
curating
um
but i think in asking your question
that's what it is really that the all of
these
these institutions obviously
universities too essentially
what people feel the people who run them
is essentially the same
and so therefore they were all jumping
on this opportunity um and it will go on
um
you ask why are they being indulged i
mean i would
say to you know you're talking about
people with influence
and power you know
aren't you
i mean these people are influential
they're in powerful positions so so it's
you know
they've got the power they've got the
influence um
all that most people can do i think
is to
just withdraw
boycott
they or they can withdraw for example
with the national trust they can say
that says i'm not you know i'm
counseling my membership or you know if
you say this happens say like at the um
imperial museum don't donate
you know people have a lot of power uh
in this way i i you know if they did it
on it on on a big enough scale same same
works for corporations as well same for
companies
you know i stopped using gillette
no idea
i just had to use this thing called
harry's do you know how yes it's a small
thing they made hay while the sun shone
during that period and good luck good
luck to them they've probably gone woke
now too but anyway
but someone needs to start real man
raises no no but you can sort of do i
think this is one area you know where
you can sort of like
because people say what can we do about
it i said well just stop using x or stop
going to y or withdraw your you know any
support you give to this and eventually
eventually it will have an effect
because money means a lot to these
people
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one-on-two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
it's sad though peter isn't it it's sad
it's tragic it's tragic to see where the
bbc is to see so what what they create
the output that they make because
you're you're an englishman i presume at
one point you loved what the bbc made oh
i quite when you if you were you know
people of my i was about 60 people of my
generation
uh you know you were shaped by the bbc
the comedy well the comedy but also like
the proms
and these great drama series but that's
just just not there anymore
it's just not there occasionally we were
talking before we came on about a good
documentary that you saw you know
occasionally but just
basically i can't help feeling that the
cultural damage they do is now greater
than any benefit
you know and i think what was shown now
was the way in which they
along with like the museums we're
talking about
last year with the proms
uh
they really did say you know they did it
again this is a perfect opportunity for
us to refresh the way we do last night
as well because they hate i'm sure the
movies hate doing the last night at the
prom oh
blokes with with uni with union jacks
and all the rest of it so essentially uh
you know but obviously what happened
there is that people
uh you know rallied on social media if
nothing else but enough to make them
change their mind peter do you think
do you think this civilization the
western civilization do you think that
you're being punished for your success
do you think that's it i think that
there is uh
i think there's an element of sort of a
cultural envy uh in it i think um
but
i think it's
a bit of that but also it's just perhaps
that we have
um
we've sort of basically become too
comfortable in a way that's not to say
that there isn't sort of
hardship in society and of course there
isn't
inequality more i think than you know
like a few decades ago
but i think that it is probably a lot to
do with that
um
but also i think it is just
our kind of
self-criticism
and our our sort of basically your
self-hatred is sort of being
utilized
um
president
trump whatever you think of him
uh he made two great speeches i think
and one of them was the one he made in
poland in 2017 and he said the biggest
question of our time is does the west
have the will to survive
and i think he was absolutely correct
though
to identify that because all the stuff
we've been talking about
um he's all essentially comes under this
one
banner i think
i think russian civilization is a
fantastic thing and it's not without
thoughts or whatever but the thoughts
are always pointed out to us
so i don't worry about you know taking
that on i think it's a it's a it's a
wonderful thing um and i just wish that
the people who were
in control of it felt the same way
it seems more and more that we're and
this particularly affects the arts going
back to the arts that we're operating in
a culture of fear
people are terrified to put forward
another point of view another way of
seeing the world particularly
artistically when
the industries around the arts and the
arts themselves are cripplingly woke
oh well they particularly are
particularly bad i mean they always were
when i was
working in them but you know they are
particularly bad i think there was some
um
there was a letter done to the times
um
by all these uh big honchos in the arts
during the referendum campaign
and it was like
thousands of them you know actors
actresses or whatever and they were all
to a man and woman
absolutely auntie you know uh brexit
um and they put forward these sort of
ideas oh we're going to be impoverished
i'll get this
our creative imagination as a country
will be impoverished
what are they talking about you know i
mean
this is you know
the eu had been around for what 50 60
years
um and hello what i mean what about
shakespeare
you know what about dickens what about
whoever else you want to mention
uh who who predated the eu but no this
is what they sort of felt um and what
they wrote
and it is sort of particularly in the
arts
hence you will not see that play i
mentioned earlier
or
you know uh increasingly as well they're
not going to take on radical islam are
they you know there are consequences
there are consequences
um so i think there's a lot of
self-censorship probably going on
um and but i think the difference now
and uh you know lionel shriver issues uh
she was talking about this when she came
on youth i know you've had
she uh
was saying you know it's to stay in your
lane thing as a writer
and so basically so what that means is
as a as a white a woman of a certain age
she you know she cannot write about i
don't know uh uh
an asylum seeker from syria or something
she can't you know she was kind of uh in
this new kind of world in which we live
i mean to me that's
just absolute impoverishment of the
imagination and uh
in every way it is an impoverishment of
the imagination and it's enforced
impoverishment because the greatest form
of censorship is self-censorship we know
that we had david bedeau on the show you
know lefty liberal
comedian and even he said that he's
self-centered when he was writing his
material
in a way that he didn't do before
yes i suppose that's very honest of him
to say that i mean i don't think it's
necessarily i don't know whether he
should have said that but
or indeed whether he should should do it
um
but i mean i i think you know
if you start if you want to have any
kind of
effect you've got to be authentic
haven't you and you've got to be
authentically yourself but
peter that's easy for us to say
it's much harder for a comedian who
wants to have a mainstream career
because the moment you become authentic
they'll push you out
they'll push you out and and we knew
when we started trigonometry we had a an
episode called the truth about
trigonometry chronicling our history of
the show and all the struggles we've
been with the reality is when we sat
down in a pub
three and a half years ago to start this
i said to francis they're going to try
and destroy us i said it to him that day
because i knew it would happen because
it's what happens to anyone who tries to
be authentic
and say the truth i mean you mentioned
radical islam look at the last month in
this country so david damas gets
murdered what do he gets murdered by as
far as we know an uh an islamist
terrorist what do mps talk about are
they talking about radical islam are
they talking about counter-terrorism no
they're talking about online anonymity
right so they're not if if our members
of parliament are not going to have an
honest conversation about who our
enemies are what they want to do to this
country who it is that's actually
killing one of their colleagues how are
you going to expect a liberal comedian
to be truthful yes right
but you asked me like earlier you know
who's why is this you know why are we
indulging so if you take your the uh
people who would like presumably
commission comedians or hire comedians
who were they who why you had a chat
with one of them
but why are we indulging them well
because they've got the power
they've got the power i mean francis had
a chat with one of them the other day
tell peter yeah so uh i was talking one
of them and i was he was going to me uh
because i did my comedy set at this tv
showcase thing he and he came up to him
and he was oh i enjoyed your set it was
it was different from what you know you
normally hear from comedians
uh and and and it was uh he was so what
do you think about the comedy industry i
went well it's fundamentally biased
isn't it and he was like well how do you
mean i said well look you've got stuart
lee stuart lee would identify as being a
left wing very left you never get a
stuart lee of the right do you
and he went no you wouldn't and he went
but what's the problem with that and i
went well it's biased doesn't it it's
not balanced yeah and he went oh yeah i
suppose you're right he says well so
what would the stuart lee of the right
talk about i went well you talk about
blm for example you talk about how these
people are trained marxists you talk
about how they want to abolish
capitalism whilst living in a country
that gives them the very fruits of
capitalism and he got very he got very
very shaky at this point shook my hand
and then left really
well there you go and that's the people
who are deciding what comedy is so i
guess all i'm saying and this is not
specifically about david padille or
anyone else it's like i mean
as as an individual performer you you
know you understand art what are you
supposed to do you can do this yeah sure
you can go on youtube and start a
channel and ruin any chance you ever had
of a mainstream career until you get so
big they have to get you in
but that is not a path that many people
are going to be willing to walk no i
look i totally
understand i would had uh one of these
panel discussions recently it was that
the
you know the great thing the institute
of ideas battling the idea battle of
ideas yeah and you know and there was
one guy who's saying you know we've lost
our guts and we've got to have courage
and you know the title is very easily
said and done but you know if you are if
you're not in the public eye i say and
if you are if you just got a
a a steady job
you've got a family it's all very well
to become a hero and everything like
that you're more like i can understand
why people would go along and do the
unconscious bias training and all of
that
even though i think it's appalling
but i can totally get it so um i'm not
sort of saying i'm not being too harsh i
think
i hope on people but i think that really
we've sort of identified it's just that
people who would hire and fire you
or people who will commission you or
people who decide what exhibits should
be in
museums and people who publish books and
people who
commission dramas and people who make
films all of these people
they're the ones who essentially i think
would be
quite similar i think in a way to
what your guys said and the worries as
well so ben shapiro is starting what a
conservative
film company an arts company etc
and look
good luck to ben and i hope he's a
success in it and i hope he produces
great films and great art
i don't want to live in a world like
that peter no no i don't want liberal i
don't i want art
i just want art yes
well
yes i mean i
i totally get it but i i think that
unfortunately
um everything has been politicized now
um and this is a big quandary i mean
this is a big quantity for many people
what do they do and do they actually
give up doing these things uh do they
do they go off and sort of like
there's a great book out uh
called the benedictine option by rodria
dreyer
american writer and he's essentially
saying how do you live in this kind of
society how do you live in a decline
where there is well you can go off
rather like the name of the rose you
know in the monks you can go off and you
can you can actually sort of get
together the very best
actually what we've got and you can just
love it and you can live amongst beauty
and all of that um or you know
essentially you just keep trying to
fight what you think is wrong you say i
don't want to live in a world like that
well what do you do fast
do you stop doing your show here no you
don't you know you you still do it um so
i say you should go on i i know that i
couldn't sort of
just and i have friends you've more or
less done that they've decided to uh you
know have a nice
quiet life that's that's not fair to
them but they you know they don't want
to they've had enough
uh but whereas i should think well
actually i'm just going to be shouting
at my non-existent tv
actually no no i'm just going to be too
angry yeah you know what i'm not a kind
of angry person
yeah i think i i i'm not i'd i'm not
going to speak for you but for for me
it's an inability to shut up
i just can't
i just yeah i just can't when i see
these people i just
i'm just francis don't [ __ ] it up again
don't do it again things no yeah i've
started speaking before i know i'm back
where i started
yeah well i i think the answer peter if
if we can sort of chart one before we
wrap up is
the reality is the
the truth outs in the end it just does
uh and the success of the new culture
forum trigonometry and all sorts of
other things
you know you can see this you know three
years ago
francis and i would never have had an
agent who can help us get our [ __ ] live
shows out into the big theaters now we
do
we've got tv commissioners
and they're very very
you know they're very few and far
between and very reluctant and all of
that but
once it happens once you break through
once you show that you've got the
numbers the people want to watch that
instead of that crap that they're
putting out
money talks and i think eventually
that's what will happen well i mean i
don't know you know the agent you
mentioned say all the commissioning uh
they you said like this kind of solitary
figures maybe uh what these people
should do is they should they should
band together and start bigger agencies
you know
and and be quite unapologetic we are you
know we
we've got no talk with any of this time
this is what we are you know that's i
think to bring us right back to what we
started on uh that is i think what
people have got to do in the future in
the long term future
well we shall see what happens peter but
in the meantime keep up the good work
thank you very much
i've had such a lovely time thank you
very much no it's been an absolute
pleasure it's been wonderful
and we do still have uh questions for
our local supporters of course
but before that our final question as
always is what is the one thing we're
not talking about as a society as we
really should be
i would say
this society would be demographics
tell us more oh okay i thought it was
one of you it's just a word
it's just a word um i was you know
basically enormous demographic change
um and because all of our politicians
are short-term merchants
um it's always like kicked into longer
50 60 years time uh you know we're not
going to be here and all the rest but um
what the implications are generally for
our society
when there is considerable demographic
change and um i think that uh you know
when the census comes out in london for
example we'll see a dramatic change uh
there already was in
2011. and i think you'll see that even
more um i'm not by the way saying uh
that it's got to be a negative thing um
i have my views on it but we should at
least be talking about it i think
from what angle peter what what i don't
really know the effect of example on
whether we can
you know uh say like what our religion
will be um
uh what
traditions we will still have or not
can i can i make that a bit more
concrete so
are you saying that you have concerns
about the impact of mass immigration yes
and how that will transform this country
50 60 70 80 years down the line yes i
mean you know it's it's not just an
economic thing it's also a cultural
thing
um and uh you know i think that you know
this
uh basically because nothing is
happening with migration there are going
to be obviously big changes they should
at least be discussed should they not
uh you might want a country that sort of
rather is identifiably britain or you
might not care about it but whatever it
is we are not talking about it
it should be it is the most taboo out of
all the taboos really isn't it what why
do you think that that and whether trans
women are real women yeah exactly
i think uh very much for the same sort
of reasons we've gone through everything
we've discussed
fear that you know
uh fear being called racist all of this
stuff
all of this stuff peter it's been
absolutely wonderful if people want to
find you online where is the best place
to do that um
what kind of site
[Laughter]
um
no
well basically i'm on twitter yes um but
the new culture forum is
new cultureforum.org dot uk and of
course you're on youtube yes when you
said what kind of society i thought you
were about to give us your grinder name
anyway
peter whittle thank you so much for
coming on it's been a pleasure thank you
for watching and listening uh to this as
well and we will see you very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one or raw show all of them go out at
7pm uk time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our local community using the
link below